minister this is the last day of
what people call black history month um
what have you seen this month that you
liked and what have you seen that you
didn't like
um
i've seen a lot of very interesting um
sort of talks that people have given
about black history haven't attended
them but i know that they've been
they've been happening and i'm really
pleased that people are thinking more
about black contributions to british
history so i've liked that
what i haven't liked maybe perhaps uh
interventions that seem more contrived
perhaps because
certain organizations feel that this is
something they need to do so they do it
but not necessarily in the meaningful in
a way that i think is meaningful or
shows that they are are interested in it
and to be honest i think black history
month it's become much bigger than it
used to be
because a lot of people are doing
different things different things with
it it's an american it's an american
import which hasn't always fitted
exactly with what i would call uh
british and commonwealth commonwealth
history but um what i'm also seeing is
there's politicization happening in
every sphere and i see it happening even
there where um
black history month becomes racism
history month which isn't what it should
be it should be a time for us to come
together and look at contributions which
haven't always uh
been taught because
they are you know they might be seen as
very niche or they're just not
traditionally what people thought should
be in the curriculum
is your point that um
what we call black history month is in a
sense become
white racism history month
i think i think that's that's that's the
way to put it and i remember last year i
was absolutely horrified i said this in
a speech in parliament my seven-year-old
came home from school and said we're
doing black history in this uh in school
because every other month is white
history and i was absolutely appalled by
that that is not what it's supposed to
be black history is british history it's
history that every black or white person
or asian person should be interested in
it's not something specially carved out
particularly worrying for my daughter
who is mixed race where she is being
taught that this is a special kind of
history that's different for her and i
don't want her to have this sort of um
sort of split identity i i think it's
not helpful for people to look at uh
communities as being so separate we
should be looking at what brings us all
together
you were reported as saying that you
were
less concerned about colonialism
than some other people might be
surely um slavery and colonialism are
pretty big mountains in the history
of
most black or many black people in this
country they are they are but they are
also
one of many many things that affect um
that affect black people across the
world and the context of that
conversation was actually talking about
nigeria i wasn't talking about this
country and if you go to nigeria and
talk about colonialism specifically from
the part i come from amirba person
people who say well comic book
colonialism and basically that means why
is that why is colonialism my concern
and that's because the debate in that
country has moved on to contemporary
issues so yes colonialism is a fact it
is something that happened but you look
at what's happening in nigeria at the
moment with extreme islamic terrorism
with the value of the currency
completely um being uh decimated with
the economy not doing well there was a
really interesting article in the
economist about about nigeria those are
the things which concern nigerians today
and as a first generation immigrant my
family still live there those are the
things that i'm very interested in
talking about and there's also a more
important point around this that when we
focus on the things that have gone wrong
uh in the past you know certain elements
we also stop thinking about the things
that make countries successful white
people don't have to talk about the
crimean war or the suez canal and so on
why is it that when it comes to black
people we are again restricted to
specific topics which we need to
demonstrate that we are correct or
saying the right things um on those
things and why is it that a debate which
you can have
very easily and
an opinion that is actually more popular
in nigeria that colonialism is not the
root of its problems is something that
cannot be said in the uk i think that's
an interesting question well
let's
let's look at that
is that really true that people would
say
in nigeria now colonialism isn't but it
doesn't matter but it's not that big a
deal when for example nigeria is itself
uh
a consequence
of a colonial division of africa i mean
nobody in their right mind would
naturally
put
yoruba yeah and ebol
in the same country that was a
consequence of colonialism yes and
nigeria's more recent history
is completely shaped by that you can't
really say colonial doesn't matter
because wouldn't exist that wouldn't
exist without colonialism but that's not
what they say
if in fact that is the biggest issue
when you look at and i'm straight into
into foreign affairs now that is the
country and the way it has been
constituted workable i think that's what
it was alluded to in that economist
article i think we need to look at those
things that do make countries well run
looking again
at
free trade looking at free markets
having very strong rule of law
property rights all of those things
those are the things that people should
be talking about now it's not saying
that colonialism had no impact or it
doesn't even have a lasting impact but
what can we do about uh the problems
that a country faces today and i think
that's where the argument should be and
there are many other people who are
having the debate about race and
colonialism i don't think that that's
wrong but why should i be forced to have
their opinions there is something
changing in the way that we in the way
that we have debates in society now that
it isn't about different opinions it's
about allowed opinions and unallowed
opinions i'm often reading about how i'm
under fire you know when when officials
bring they bring newspaper articles
against minister under fire uh for
saying this i really am i under fire i
don't feel under fire and then they show
me some very angry people on twitter who
i haven't actually taken any notice of
black lives matter movement had a huge
global impact
broadly speaking
a good thing or not a good thing
um i think with
the phrase black lives matter very much
a good thing
we have been able to focus a lot on
where there's discrimination in society
or across the globe even where there are
disparities what is causing those
disparities there's a lot of work in
government um which we've been doing in
order to find out uh what is causing
differences in outcomes and what we can
do about them i think that that has been
a good thing
where it has become a vehicle for
smuggling in other themes
probably less so because those many of
those things are not values which i
share
but
that doesn't mean that it should be
stopped or or banned you know i believe
in freedom of speech and freedom of
expression it's a different um it's
often quite uh when you look at the you
know defund the police and other things
the people who claim to speak for that
movement uh
what those things that they put forward
or they purport i do disagree with those
things i don't think those are these are
good things but in terms of focusing on
how we can improve disparities and
reduce prejudice and discrimination yes
you have responsibility for the health
equalities brief we've been talking
about race but of course one of the hot
issues right now is trans
what people call trans rights and that's
been
become an issue partly because of
what people can
can say without being contested or
cancelled or whatever
the right expression is
the big example recently has been that
of
kathleen stock at sussex university who
it is thought may lose her position
because she is what's called a gender
critical feminist ie she believes
in the biological reality of sex where
do you stand on this so on kathleen
stock i was appalled at the way that she
was treated and in fact i i went to
sussex university and i tweeted when i
saw the university statement backing her
nobody should face bullying or
harassment in the workplace that is
actually another thing that the um that
the equality act looks at bullying and
harassment i don't think she should lose
her job and i think that she has every
right to hold the beliefs which she does
i think she is probably in step with the
majority of the population and what we
in government are trying to do is show
that we do believe
um that trans people should be free to
live their lives as they wish but where
people see a conflict and that conflict
has tended to be around single sex
spaces and
where the gender reassign and the
definition of gender reassignment and
how uh gender critical feminists as they
are known believe that those rights are
in conflict what we can do in order to
um provide clarity so the government
position is that
we will do everything we can to support
trans uh people in particular all lgbt
people but trans people in particular
when it comes to health care because
they have different health care needs
from other lgbt people however we do not
think that that goes as far as self id
we do believe that there should be a
process to get a gender recognition
certificate um rather than for people
and the process does mean involving
medical professionals as well
some trans activists would say that the
fact that you do not accept the
statement that trans women are women is
in itself a form of violence you are
what is called a turf a trans
radical feminist i i think it's sad that
the the debate has turned into one of
name calling what i would ask people to
do is actually look at what the policies
are what it is we're doing in order to
protect people of all types
whether they are lgbt
uh of different race uh racial
backgrounds uh the different sexes we
are a government that believes in
equality and fairness for all and
everything we're doing is to make sure
that we have a an equal society and we
should not get to a point where having a
different opinion becomes a reason to
insult other people that's absolutely
wrong